[Musique]
le gros problème que vous avez c'est que
vous faites un flex comme vous récitez
une poésie aujourd'hui au lycée
Sainte-Geneviève les joueurs qui
participeront au match de basket face au
lycée Hoche répète leur fondamentaux les
sportifs s'entraînent collectivement
chaque semaine et parfois le soir
individuellement afin d'être prêt pour
ce match amical programmer le 16 février
bah tu l'as une dernière ils veulent
prendre leur revanche face à leur Evo
depuis quelques semaines les gens le
Ginette commencent à leur trotter dans
la tête et on commence vraiment à se
donner à fond et on sent une
vraieulation c'est super sur le terrain
montant d'intensité on monte ensuite au
niveau forcément parce que la pression
ça joue c'est un jeu de mental au final
le basket donc forcément les gens se
donnent un enfant parce qu'ils ont envie
de te donner au génital entraînement
intensif également du côté des
cheerleaders du lycée Sainte-Geneviève
alseront le spectacle sur le parquet
pendant les pauses
chaque semaine pendant une heure et plus
de 30 cheerleaders sont présentes pour
répéter elle travaille sur la
chorégraphie depuis fin octobre en fait
l'idée c'est de faire beaucoup de
[Musique]
avec plein de références à Ginette si
possible
à fille avec la danse et puis donc les
porter ce qu'on appelle stunt donc des
filles qui volent dans les airs etc ici
l'équipe est entièrement gérée par des
élèves objectifs réalisés un show à la
hauteur de l'événement et surtout à la
hauteur des cheerleaders du lycée Hosh
bien sûr tout le monde a envie d'avoir
le plus belle chorégraphie et on a
vraiment hâte de découvrir la Corée que
Hoche à préparer parce qu'à chaque fois
c'est très inspirant justement du côté
du lycéoch on prépare également
l'événement entre les cours depuis la
rentrée comme pour leur rivaux la
préparation est intensive
[Musique]
deux entraînements sont organisés chaque
semaine avec notamment au programme des
portées franchement on est pas mal du
tout on a quasi on présente quatre
chorégraphies et là on est en train de
terminer aujourd'hui la quatrième et
dernière chorégraphie ce gens qui nous
reste encore quelques entraînements donc
en fait ensuite ce sera juste de la
répétition donc on est vraiment bien là
sur le terrain de basket 12 chaque
semaine ici les élèves se sont
improvisés coach ces derniers mois pour
construire une équipe compétitive ils
ont un objectif en tête regagné à
nouveau on a fait des sélections au
début d'année donc beaucoup de joueurs
sont venus on a pris ce qu'on jugeait
avec les meilleurs puis on a commencé
les entraînements donc on a commencé
déjà par jauger un peu le niveau tout le
monde par des entraînements un peu
basiques pour voir les fondamentaux puis
on a joué au fur et à mesure ensemble
puis après on a créé une espèce de
cohésion on va dire et on a commencé à
développer des tactiques entre
guillemets et jouer quoi ils ont tous
hâte maintenant de commencer ce match
qui n'a d'amical que le nom ce jeudi 16
février à 20h et le jour où devant plus
de 1300 élèves au gymnase mauborant de
Versailles dans une ambiance bouillante
pour l'instant sur le plan comptable
Ginette mène 14 à 2 dans les
confrontations face à au